what is your thoughts on
the afterlife
are you a believer
a non-believer
and Once Upon a Time in my early
twenties
I would be quite aggressive
towards people who
would talk about anything that
cannot be seen
or understood
in class in the total rubbish
white-toed rubbish
because people are weird
believing in stupid things
you are what you are in life
and you shouldn't believe in stupid
things talking about spirits
the date
ghosts
when you're dead you're dead
nobody can prove otherwise
but just a minute
what about something profound happens to
you
you don't have to go off and become a
Buddhist monk
or start living some
perfect religious life
where you must not only be a good person
I talk about meditation trance spiritual
beliefs
I'm not talking about religion to me
they're inside the boxes
some will say it's all the same
you have to be religious to believe in
the spirit world
believing God to believe in angels
but why do I have to believe in
everything
but people tell me I have to
you may have the same opinion
just let's say you go along with me just
for the sake of listening
and the camera down I in front of us
with all this items
[Music]
and having a special ceremony done
in 1992.
and were
certain Spirits put in there while they
decided that yes they would
honor the
the time taken to go through the
religious ceremony
we provided all the things that were
necessary to make the blessing and the
action to come true
so perhaps
in this
camera down
I may have
one two or three Spirits behind the
doors I don't know who they are if they
are there or perhaps it's my vivid
imagination
this happened to me before but when I
first
got the stall out
placed in front of the shaman
as I sat down I closed my eyes
and just as if an earthquake had
happened beneath me
I felt this tremendous walking and
instability
and yet there I am sitting on the stove
just about to prepare
to get ready for this
quiet moment but we just gaze in
the showman but my focus
is on the camera gamma
and as I close my eyes
was it then
just telling me that they're happy to be
here
they've been sealed up and kept in a
safe place above ground
for the last
baby and a half years
and then
I make a new Dojo a new Showman
and place
the old man with all the things not the
love and care that it takes
redesign
a new Showman
in hopes that not just myself but others
will be happy
so were the spirits
or the come on
as we call them
are they just high level Spirits from
the afterlife
were they just telling me they are here
and they're happy
as I felt it before months before
this
quite dramatic movie of me
as if I've all of a sudden
lost my balance
and yet I knew I hadn't lost my balance
because I'm sitting on my medestation
stop
I'm sitting
on my knees
and my back sides on the stove
the ground is found
and yet the demanding walking and
movement
came with something else
it came with voices
for watches that I don't recognize
and yeah I do recognize them
and I will tell you in another segment
of my experience when I have heard this
before
and when I felt the same
dramatic sensation
of almost the Earth opening up
and rocking the
and feeling that I had no stability
Within Myself And The Power of spirit
is telling me
they are with me
and so if I wish then to
speak
ask a question
or just sit in their presence
then everything I know
is the correct way to think and to act
so in this particular innocent
after the the rocking and the movement
and the imbalancing of my body
it's like holding on clutching onto the
edge
of something no or hoping that it will
pass
and it does pass
but while this is going on
many many voices
I'll try to
scroll up what I mean oh
can you imagine
[Music]
all these sounds we need Mount your ears
bring me with your head
not knowing where to look where's The
Voice is coming from
and yet you've heard them before
oh my God I'm mad
if I got a vivid imagination
when I was younger I would say yes
but now
I know better
I hope you've enjoyed this
it's a true story
and what you can gaze into the
screen here
Little Dave
look past me
silver disc
look to the doors question what's in
there
who knows you may get an insight
and I'm
going to tell you more about when it
first happened
why it happened
and when it happened
thank you for listening